We've reviewed several times already,
at least some of the stuff for your paper this week.
If you're writing a paper on,
um,
Judaism and the law in early Christianity,
different varieties,
if you'll remember,
and I've heard I've reviewed this several times,
so this is just really briefly,
but domain,
one of the main themes of the whole course is the diversity of early
Christianity.
How many different times of early Christianity's there were.
And one of the important things is always to look at that is what were their
different views of the law.
So of course with Matthew,
as we've seen,
Matthew treats the law,
the Jewish law as something that apparently he considers his the followers of
his own church,
uh,
to continue to keep.
There's no hint in Matthew that the law would be abrogated.
Uh,
it's interpreted of course.
So some of the aspects of the sabbath observance Jesus interprets differently in
Matthew then do say the Pharisees in Matthew or the scribes and Matthew are
other Jews.
So,
but Matthew's tends to give us the idea that the law is just there to be
observed by everybody.
When we got to Luke acts,
we saw that the NOAA hide laws,
that is the laws given after the flood to Noah,
which are only,
uh,
four of them,
right?
You don't eat things that are strangled.
You don't eat blood ya,
you don't eat.
You don't sacrifice idols.
An idol meat and I can't work.
One of them was,
but there are certain laws that the Jews considered were given to Noah after the
flood and that all peoples,
even gentiles were expected to follow those rules.
But the Jews didn't expect gentiles to keep other peculiarly Jewish laws.
Jews never expected gentiles not to eat pork,
to keep the sabbath,
to circumcise their children,
and they never thought there was anything wrong with gentiles doing those
things.
Of course,
that's one of the things that separated them from the Jews.
Luke acts seems to take that kind of view of the law,
that the law is an ethnic,
the ethnic customs of the Jews,
similar to the ways that the Romans would have their own laws and customs.
The Greeks would have their own laws and customs.
The Egyptians who have their laws and customs,
the Babylonians,
the Persians would have their laws and customs.
So that seems to be the way the Jewish laws treated.
Uh,
in Luke and acts,
Paul,
we've talked about Paul in Romans and Galatians.
He has a much more radical teaching about the law that the law is.
Uh,
Paul never says that Jewish followers of Jesus,
uh,
shouldn't keep the law,
but he certainly discourages in fucking forbids gentile converts to keep the
law.
He in Galatians,
he says,
you,
who would be justified by the law that you've cut out,
you're cut off from grace.
So Paul has a much more radical position and we could look at others.
You talked,
we talked about Marcien member Marcien from the very beginning of the course,
the guy who,
uh,
in the second century in Rome,
he taught a version of Christianity in which he only had recognized the gospel
of Luke and just the letters of as his,
he was the first one to come up with a canon list,
we think.
And then he edited those to wear anything positive about,
uh,
the Jewish law or the God of the Jews,
was taken out because he believed that was a junior false bad god and not the
father of Jesus Christ.
So Marcian throughout the whole Hebrew Bible,
the scriptures of Jews entirely and substituted for Jewish scripture,
uh,
his own edited version of Luke and the golf and the letters of Paul.
So all of these are different ways that early Christians talked about what to do
about the law.
We'll get to some of that again in James Today because we can,
you can read James as Luther and some other people read it as being basically a
disagreement with Pauline Christianity.
We'll talk about whether that's a good reading of James or not,
but quite often,
especially in Protestant Christianity,
James has been read to be arguing against Paul's law,
Free Gospel or justification by faith,
by grace,
through faith alone.
Before we get to James,
I want to highlight one other aspect that we've talked about a bit,
but I want to review it again as another illustration of the diversities of
early Christianity.
And this is our wonderful favorite topic.
Christologies we've talked about Chris.
Dot.
Different Christologies all along.
We've looked at everyone's in John and that sort of thing,
but let's just look at a few texts and read them together.
First,
look at Luke.
Of course,
Christology Christologies you recall is what do you believe about Christ?
What kind of nature is Jesus Christ or was Jesus Christ?
Luke three 22.
Okay.
The Holy Spirit descended upon Jesus in bodily form like a dove and a voice came
from heaven.
You are my son,
the beloved with whom?
With you.
I am well pleased.
Now if you notice,
that's a quotation from the song.
You can see it down in your footnotes.
If you have a study Bible,
Psalm two,
seven and also at sites.
Isaiah 42 one if you also know there are some little words,
um,
a little numbers that have footnotes.
Probably if you,
it's certainly in the new revised standard version.
The letter footnote numbers.
There's one that says other ancient authorities read.
You are my son today.
I have been gotten you.
I've talked about this already in the class.
Now the the debate among scholars would be was today I have the gotten you
originally in Luke's Gospel and then some scribe took it out because we do find
it in some Greek manuscripts or was it not there originally in Luke's Gospel and
other scribes put it in.
Okay,
nice question.
Did the original gospel of Luke have today I had the gotten you said by the
voice from heaven at the baptism of Jesus or not.
Now,
why would this be an important issue?
Because if the voice from heaven saying,
today I have the gotten you,
which is a quote from the psalm after all,
then wouldn't that imply that Jesus was not the son of God yesterday and that's
exactly the way some Christians took it.
They believe that Jesus became the son of God.
He wasn't born the son of God.
He was adopted as the son of God and some Christian said it was at his baptism
and they would cite some Greek version of this text.
Now,
scholars have debated about whether it was rigid in a text.
If it's not in the text,
how it get there,
what a scribe would see this.
Uh,
you are my beloved son and the scribe might know the songs very well and might
know that the next line of the Psalm was today I had the gotten you and so just
quoted it almost from memory from the psalm and therefore it got into the text
or as Bart Ehrman,
the author of your textbook has said,
Bart actually became very famous first as a text critic of the New Testament.
That is his profession,
was trying to figure out what was the most likely original reading of the Greek
New Testament texts by comparing all these different manuscripts.
And he's argued that he thinks that maybe the texts originally said today I had
been gotten you and Orthodox scribes took it out in the second century.
And you can tell why Orthodox scribes may have taken it out if they thought that
that gave weight to an adoption is Christology,
which they considered heretical.
They would take it out of the text.
So it's an,
it's an open question that some scholars say they think that today had the
gotten you was not originally,
and therefore they agree with the new revised standard version and not putting
it in the Bible,
but putting it in a footnote in stead.
And others would agree with Bart Ehrman and say,
no,
it probably was in the text and an Orthodox scribes took it out because it
didn't sound orthodox for them.
Anyway,
that's a clue that one of the Chris' Dolly's uses was around and was debated in
the second century was precisely was Jesus born son of God or did he become son
of God by adoption at his baptism?
And you've and a psalm two seven is the one that you can look that up also.
Now look at Luke nine 35,
nine 35 also in Luke.
Where am I?
Okay.
Then a cloud came from,
uh,
then from the cloud came a voice.
This is at the transfiguration of Jesus.
Remember when he's up on the mountain and he,
his clothing changes,
his face changes.
You start shining.
Now,
here's what the voice from heaven says this time,
this is my son,
my chosen.
Listen to him,
Again,
that sounds like God.
The father chose Jesus maybe because of his special righteousness to be his son.
Look at acts two 36 now.
Acts of course,
written by the same person who wrote Luke.
So we're not changing authors here.
We're just changing books.
X Two 36 this is in a speech,
a sermon,
one of the first sermon in acts by Peter.
So on the day of Pentecost,
you know the story,
the spirit in flames come down and rest on the Christians and they all start
speaking in tongues and languages of everybody around the world.
Then Peter gives a sermon to 36,
therefore let the entire house of Israel.
Now this is the way he ends the sermon.
So this is an emphatic position in the text.
This is the end of Peter's sermon.
Let the entire house of Israel know with certainty that God has made him both
Lord and Messiah.
This Jesus whom you crucified has made him again,
that idea.
Look at acts 1333.
Uh,
go back to verse 32 and we bring you the good news.
That what?
That what God promised to ours.
Ancestors,
he has fulfilled for us,
their children by raising Jesus as also it is written in the second song.
You are my son today.
I have been gotten you.
Oh,
now that's now.
It's the today.
But what is the day that this text seems to be referring to the resurrection.
So is this a hint that there were other Christians who believed that Jesus was
human until he was raised from the dead,
and that's when he became divine and the son of God.
Look at Romans now we're going to go to Paul.
Romans one.
Yeah.
Romans chapter one verses three and four,
which he promised beforehand through his prophets in the Holy Scriptures,
the Gospel concerning his son who was descended from David according to the
flesh and was declared to be son of God with power according to the spirit of
holiness by resurrection from the dead.
Now I would dispute that translation.
The Greek there that's translated by your Bible as declared,
at least by the NRSV,
I think is actually better translated as a point our designate.
Does anybody else have a different word for declare in that verse?
Let me read it again.
You look at verses three and four of Romans one,
verse four,
and was declared to be son of God with power according to the spirit of
holiness,
by resurrection from the dead.
Anybody else have a different word than declare?
Yes,
yes.
Designated.
See,
that's exactly the word I would have used.
Is there a difference?
Well,
it could be.
There could be a slight difference in,
in the idea,
didn't Jesus,
did God just announce that Jesus was divine at his resurrection or did he make
him designate him?
Like when you designate someone to be the leader of the class,
to be the president of the United States,
you designate to an office and it's at the designation of the office office.
That's the actual person becomes that official.
I think that's actually the better translation of the Greek.
That again though would imply that Paul May be quoting a,
an uh phrase that he's maybe gets from elsewhere that believed that Jesus became
the son of God divine at his resurrection.
Now,
of course I say Paul quoting something because there are other indications in
Paul that he probably didn't believe that Paul seems to,
I'd give the idea to other places that he can hit a Christology that Jesus was
preexistent as divine.
In Philippians,
you get the,
the famous hymn where Christ descends into the body and is suffers as a slave
and his raised back up there,
you almost get the idea that Paul believed that Jesus was in a preexistent state
as some,
as the son of gun.
So this may not be Paul's own considered theology,
Christology,
and therefore Pete some scholars who said,
maybe he's quoting along that it gets from some of those,
but it does show us that there may have been other Christians who believe that
Jesus became divine only at his resurrection.
In other words,
we can map out all these differences.
And of course,
what does the gospel of John,
what would the god,
what was the Christology of the gospel of John?
When did Jesus Become divine according to the gospel of John?
Anybody?
He always was.
He was with God and very beginning,
everything was created through him.
So the Gospel,
the beginning of the gospel of John,
ends up having the Christology that now has become Orthodox Christianity and
these other Christologies.
We're all declared heretical at some point in Christian history.
But notice how what we've got,
let's say we've got the historical Jesus,
and we can say certainly he was a prophet.
He was recognized as a prophet.
He seems to accept himself as a prophet,
and it may be that he claimed to be a king or a messiah,
but certainly by the time of his,
his execution,
some people thought he was a king because that's the charge on which he was
executed.
This is Jesus of Nazareth,
King of the Jews.
So the Romans executed Jesus because at least either he or other people were
claiming that he was a king.
So he's a prophet and he's a king.
Does that mean Jesus divine?
No,
of course not.
The Jews had lots of kings that were not divine did.
You just has lots of profits that we're not denying divine modern.
People sometimes get the idea that the word Christ or Messiah in itself
signifies divinity,
but it doesn't.
The Messiah in,
in Paul's Day,
in Jesus' Day was simply some Jewish figure who would rise up and take over the
throne of David and reestablish the Kingdom of Israel.
So calling someone a messiah in the ancient world didn't mean that he was
divine.
It might,
but it didn't necessarily at all.
So Jesus is a prophet.
Maybe he's even considered the messiah that doesn't make him a divine.
Some Christians though for head to make a decision,
is he human
and only human or is he human?
Okay
and divine.
This is the take that most followers of Jesus ended up taking.
Although there were some followers of Jesus who existed all the way into the
second century who believed he was just,
he was purely human.
They tended to be Jewish followers of Jesus.
They accept them as a great prophet.
David except them has been psi.
But that didn't mean they thought it was God.
They still want it to be complete monotheist and have only God,
only one God.
So they said,
no,
Jesus can't be divine.
So some followers of Jesus chose this route.
Others,
as we've seen in the New Testament,
chose this route.
Then though you have to split this up.
When did he become,
uh,
was he always divine or did he become divine?
Am I doing this right Jen?
Jen,
is this the next level?
I had this chart in my notes,
but I gave it to Jan Jan cause I thought she might have to lecture today and uh,
I forgot it.
So we're winging it folks.
He became divine.
He always was divine.
Yeah.
So if he became divine,
then when did he become divine and you had different choices again,
like we said
at his birth,
because then you have the songs that all the angels sing and,
and you take some of those songs,
the beginning of Luke,
and it sounds like they're talking about his divine.
Now Ed is a baptism.
As we've seen.
Some people tend to believe art is resurrection.
Okay,
so Christians again seem to have divided up.
Do you take him as becoming divided,
his birth,
his baptism or his resurrection?
We've seen other Christians say no,
he always was defined.
But even then,
they split up into different choices too because some of them,
um,
believed that he was,
they still said he was divine,
but also fully human.
So he was both divine but also fleshly.
Okay.
Where are we seeing this people,
a letter in the new testament insisting that you can't have Jesus as divine
without also having him has come in the flesh.
Do you remember first John,
exactly like the letters of John?
Get into this argument?
Apparently some people in the Johanan community,
we're climbing,
that Jesus was fully divine but not fleshly.
And then you have,
so this became
that position flush and divine.
And the other position I called it when I'd lectured on John Docetism,
that is what came to be a heresy.
Remember in the second century,
there was no organized church that could be able to declare what counted is
orthodoxy and heresy.
But this idea was Jesus was not fully flesh.
He was so,
he was so divine.
He was God.
So they,
when he walked along the or wet sand on the beach,
his foot,
his feet didn't leave footprints.
That's how divine he was.
He didn't have any weight about him.
He was not even fully flesh.
Cause I notice all of these are choices that followers of Jesus had to make in
the decades following his death.
Some of them took the human routes,
some of them took the human and divine route.
Some of them took this,
that he became divine.
This became declared as a heresy.
We call it adoptionism of some sort.
Then of those who took the always divine route,
which we became orthodoxy,
some of them also took the [inaudible] route that he wasn't fully few human
fleshly and then others took this route like the gospel of John Does and the
letters of John,
that he is both fleshly and divine.
Now,
all of those,
notice how what this shows is it from simply the the historical existence of
Jesus and his existence as a prophet or a king.
You had to make all these different choices to get down to this one because
which of these all these different,
we have one,
two,
three,
four,
five different possibilities down here.
Six right there,
out of six choices,
only one of them is considered orthodox by the later church.
I do this just to show these.
These diversity's are there.
Um,
if you're a Christian,
you believe that,
well,
the Holy Spirit are God's providence led the way through this history so that
what we end up with as the Nicene creed or the creative calcium is what we ought
to believe as Christians.
But as a historian,
you can't make that judgment as a historian.
You simply seem to,
he just simply have to point out that there were lots of complexities in early
Christianity that finally got whittled down into a more United consensus view on
Christology.
Any questions about any of that?
This is,
I'm,
I'm doing this partly just to show you how this happened historically,
and this actually gets you into a post new testament kind of a subject.
You could easily take a course after this,
uh,
say the one taught by Bentley Leighton or Steven Davis.
That analyze is called a course from Jesus to Augustine or something.
I think he's taken it past past.
I've Guston now that covers a little bit of the new testament texts,
but really that's of course on the development of early Christianity in its
first few centuries.
Or you can even take courses that talk about the development of Christianity all
the way up from the beginning to the reformation or even beyond.
And in any of these historic Shargel courses,
you're going to see this kind of diversity in the shaping of this that comes
about.
So part of what I'm doing is just,
uh,
illustrating the diversity of Christianity and how it came about.
But I'm also trying to model a behavior for you of thinking Theola thinking
historically about what we are actually theological text,
thinking about the growth of Christianity as if it didn't just plop out of the
sky all in one orthodox piece.
But it took a host historical process of struggle to,
uh,
come about.
And it was a complicated historical process.
Now what?
Where does that leave us with James?
James provides us another example of uh,
of differences in notions of faith and works when compared to Paul.
First,
I'm going to take some examples from Hebrew scripture.
So if you've got your Bible not haven't taught you a song for the old testament
books,
the books of Hebrew scriptures,
so you'll just have to follow along as best you can.
Proverbs and my Bible,
it's page nine oh four in the Hebrew Bible,
but that's not the Bible you have,
I would hasten to say the proverbs of Solomon,
son of David,
King of Israel
for learning about wisdom and instruction for understanding words of insight for
gaining instruction and wise dealing righteousness,
justice and equity to teach trueness to the simple knowledge improvements to the
young,
let the wise also here and gain and learning and did a surrounding acquire skill
to understand a proverb and a figure.
The words of the wise and their riddles.
The fear of the Lord is one of my mom's favorite verse when I was a kid,
caught it all the time.
To us,
the fear of the Lord is the beginning of wisdom.
Fools,
despise wisdom and instruction.
Kind of a motherly type verse,
isn't it?
That what you've got in proverbs is a whole series of teachings,
wisdom sayings.
And some of them are pretty nondescript.
It's just like,
you know,
cover your mouth when you cough type thing is there,
there are some things that aren't particularly heavy,
our philosophical or theological,
uh,
but just sayings,
wisdom.
Sangs uh,
another one of my mother's favorite ones was there was a women's Club at the
college.
She went to the Christian college you went to,
and the,
the quotation of it,
it was from this proverb,
we're just talking about a worthy woman and the quotation of the buy was her
price is far above rubies.
And that was the motto for this girl's Club.
And My mother always said,
I wonder how much ruby charges
let that sort of is a little sayings.
Like how much does ruby charge?
That's not part of the scriptures.
But the other part is part of group.
These are wisdom sayings and this is wisdom literature.
So in the Jewish scripture you have whole books that are basically wisdom
literature and scholars will use that term.
They're sayings of,
of wisdom kind of sayings.
You get it also in job.
Um,
look at job is before psalms job 14 one
Joe is also one version of wisdom literature,
a mortal barn of woman few of days and few and full of trouble comes up like a
flower.
And withers is like a shadow and does not last.
Ah,
how sad.
Notice wisdom literature isn't always very cheery.
A lot of wisdom literature is about how difficult life is.
That life is fleeting that you just come up like a flower.
You,
you're beautiful and young for you know,
two weeks and then you fade and get old and ugly and then you die.
You know,
a lot of wisdom literature is sort of like,
you know,
life's a bitch.
So just enjoy it while you can.
And that's where you get some of the sayings out of job and the proverbs,
the wisdom of Solomon that may be in your,
oh,
I don't have the wisdom of Solomon.
Uh,
in your Apocrypha,
if you have a bible that has the Apocrypha in it,
you'd find the wisdom of Solomon,
which also has a,
if you looked at the wisdom of Solomon,
six 17 through 20 has some wonderful wisdom sayings.
Uh,
sir,
Ciroc for has sayings about the poor that remembering the poor.
It's admonitions to rich people to remember the poor,
do not forsake the poor.
And Ciroc six five has a warning about speech.
Control your speech,
watch your tongue.
So notice these sayings,
things about how life is fleeting.
You come up like flowers,
like grass,
it fades,
uh,
take care of the poor.
Don't forget the poor wisdom literature often seems to be written within a
context of people who are fairly well off themselves,
rich people.
And it's written to these rich people.
But in order to also get them not to forget the poor and then in the saying
about watch your mouth control the tongue that we see in a Ciroc six five is
also there.
Now with that in mind,
all these other kinds of wisdom literature,
turn to James
and look at chapter three of James.
Yeah.
Not many of you should become teachers.
My brothers,
my translation says sisters,
but in the Greek it's just brothers for you know that we who teach will be
judged with greater strictness for all who make money.
All of us make many mistakes.
Anyone who makes no mistakes in speaking as perfect able to keep the whole body
in check with a bridle.
If we put bits into the mouths of horses to make them obey us,
we guide their whole bodies.
Notice this is just folk wisdom,
right?
Look how you control a horse.
You put a bit and its mouth.
You pull the horses mouth this way the horse goes that way.
You pull the hardest math that way the horse goes that way.
This is nothing really big revelation type stuff,
right?
This is not kind of revealing secrets of God or this is not even revealing
secrets of the Gospel.
This is not,
this is just wisdom.
That's what a lot of wisdom literature in the Bible also it looks like folk
wisdom or look at ships.
He says another example though they are so large that it takes strong winds to
drive them.
Yet they are guided by a very small rudder wherever the will of the pilot
directs.
So also the tongue is a small member yet it boasts of great exploits almost.
It just really echos that kind of stuff we've you can see in Sirach and proverbs
and those kinds of things.
So one of the things that James is the letter of James is a representation of
typical Jewish wisdom literature.
Why do I say Jewish?
Because this is actually a very Jewish document.
There's almost no mention of Christ in it.
If you took out a few sentences here and there,
the letter of James could read as a non Christian document because most of this
stuff about them,
the tongue,
how you control the tongue about remembering the poor,
all these sorts of things.
This is stuff anybody,
any Jewish person in the ancient world could have said.
It's not particularly Christian,
so that James is a,
an example of ancient,
typical Jewish wisdom literature,
but,
and here's where James becomes very interesting for Christian readings.
Look at,
okay,
keep your finger on James,
but
well,
no,
I'll,
I'll skip that.
You know?
Yes.
Let's read Romans Four.
Look at Romans four quickly.
Yeah.
Romans four one and now you're familiar with this.
You've already talked about Paul.
You've written about Paul,
you know about Paul.
What then are we to say was gained by Abraham,
our ancestor according to the flesh,
for if Abraham was justified by works,
he has something to boast about,
but not before God.
For what does the scripture say?
Abraham believed God and it was reckoned to him as righteousness.
Now keep that scripture in mind.
It's a quotation from genesis.
Abraham believed God and it was reckoned to him as righteousness.
Now to one who works wages are not reckoned as a gift,
but it's something do.
But to one who without works,
trust him,
who justifies the ungodly,
such faith as record as righteousness,
and then he goes on and makes Paul makes his argument further.
Galatians three has a very similar thing.
It quotes the same kind of Christmas scriptures from Galatians and Paul in
Galatians makes the same point.
Abraham was not justified by works.
Any quotes,
some of the very,
this very scripture to prove according to Paul,
that genesis shows that Abraham was not justified by works.
He was justified by faith.
Now look back at James
One
I should have kept my finger there.
Want to be flipping back and forth.
First Chapter of James Verses 20 through 22 through 25
but be doers of the word and not merely hearers who deceive themselves for if
any,
are hearers of the word and not doers.
They are like those who look themselves in a mirror,
look at himself in the mirror for they look at themselves and on going away
immediately.
Forget what they were like,
but those who look into the perfect law,
the law of liberty,
and persevere not being hearers who forget,
but doers who act,
they will be blessed in they're doing.
Look at James Two 14 what good is it my brothers?
If you say you have faith but do not have works,
can faith save you?
Well,
I think Paul would say,
as a matter of fact,
James.
Yes.
Yeah.
If a brother or sister is naked and lacks daily food,
and one of you says to them,
go in peace,
be warmed and eat your fill,
and yet you do not supply their bodily needs.
What good is that?
So faith by itself,
if it has no works,
is dead.
Look at 21 through 26 of the same chapter.
James Two 21 through 26
was not our ancestor.
Abraham justified by works when he offered his son Isaac on the altar.
You see that faith was active along with his works and faith was brought to
completion by the works.
Thus the scripture was fulfilled that says Abraham believed God and it was
reckoned to him as righteousness.
Notice this guy quotes the exact same verse Paul quotes,
but to make the opposite point,
Paul had quoted this very verse to argue that Abraham was justified by his
faith,
not by works.
This writer close to the same verse from Genesis to say,
Abraham was justified by works.
You see that a person is justified by works and not by faith alone likewise was
not Rayhab.
The prostitute also justified by works when she welcomed the messengers and sent
them out by another road.
This is when the Israelites were surrounding the city of Jericho before they'd
marched around it and made all the walls fall down.
Two of the spies came into Jericho and they were received by a prostitute Rayhab
for just as the body without the spirit is dead,
so faith without works is also dead.
Now this,
these texts
seem to be arguing against Paul and it makes us wonder,
does the author actually have text to Paul in front of him?
Is he actually reading Romans and Galatians and he sees that Paul quotes this
passage from genesis and therefore he coached the same patches to make the
opposite point or has he heard about Paul's Gospel,
about a works free gospel in some places and he's responding to rumors or is he
just responding to Paul Type Christians?
He may not know Paul himself and man don't even have access to Paul's work,
but he's heard some people who are followers of Paul and promote his kind of law
free faith dominated Gospel and he's writing against those kinds of people.
It's very difficult to say,
but as a lot of,
as I think Bart Ehrman in the textbook points out and other people have said all
along,
there is a way to sort of get beyond this contradiction and to say that maybe
the writer of James is not saying really the opposite of what Paul is saying.
After all.
Have you picked up on that argument?
Yes.
What do you,
what is it?
What's the argument?
Yes,
they're operating on different definitions of works and faith and that's a very
good point.
So notice for example,
for what,
what was faith for Paul faith.
And this is something that modern people,
Christians as well as non Christians,
radical atheists,
you know,
Richard Dawkins and Christopher Hitchens,
uh,
you know,
publish these books saying,
Christian or any religious people in general are crazy people who believe lots
of ridiculous things before breakfast.
And just think that that's that.
And the idea is that if you're a religious person,
you do believe that,
you know,
people go around walking on water all the time,
that hell both exist under the ground below our feet,
that God is this man with a beard who sits up in the cloud somewhere.
And so there are a lot of people who think what his religious faith,
well,
it's actually believing certain propositions.
It's believing a proposition.
Like there is a God,
God is alive in the same way that you would believe the proposition.
It's sun shining outside.
It's a proposition.
You just look at nature.
You figure it out.
Now in the Terry lectures a year ago or yeah,
by I believe a year ago.
Um,
Terry Eagleton,
who's a very famous Marxist literary critic,
but he grew up Catholic.
He gave the Terry lectures.
They've just come out in publication by Yale University press.
I recommend them very highly gay four lectures in which he took,
uh,
took on these sort of radical atheists and Terry Eagleton wasn't arguing himself
for Christian faith.
I don't even know whether he believes Christian stuff or not.
But what he was trying to argue is that what count has counted as Christian
faith over the centuries is more complicated than simply believing a proposition
that say the proposition God exists for Paul in his matter.
As a matter of fact,
having faith is more a sense of putting your trust in God.
So talking about trust,
faith for Paul is trusting God to do what you need.
So faith is not simply a belief in certain kinds of propositions,
like a scientific proposition.
It's actually an attitude of putting all of your trust in God through Jesus
Christ.
This notion,
therefore that faith is something that you believe about is not really matched
by Paul's writings on faith,
which are much more complex and they're much more like the idea that faith is a
way of living.
Faith is,
uh,
is a,
does decision.
Soren Kierkegaard the great leap of faith,
the 19th century philosopher,
faith,
faith is this willingness to just throw it all in.
Even though all the evidence might be to the contrary,
it's a,
you make,
it's a leap of faith and carry God's image.
That's what it's more like for Paul.
But notice that's not exactly what James seems to think faith is.
And this is why some people have said Paul and James are not really disagreeing
with each other because they're working with different notions of faith and
works.
So what does James say
a to 19
James Two 19.
You believe that God is one.
You do well,
even the demons believe and shudder.
Ah,
see that's a pretty big clue.
Do you think Paul would've ever said that demons have faith in Christ?
No.
Paul actually doesn't talk about demons enough for us to really be sure.
He only mentions demons once in all of his letters.
And that's in First Corinthians 10 and he's just talking,
took the courage and saying,
don't participate in idle sacrifices because that's participating in the table
of demons.
But Paul's not too concerned about demons,
but he doesn't.
I think it'd be outlandish to think that Paul would have considered demons as
having faith in Christ.
Demons believe that Christ exists.
Polity.
Yeah,
of course they know.
Damon's know God exists.
Name is no Christ exist.
So that's not what Paul's definition of Christian faith is.
But that is what James seems to be thinking.
Faith is it simply the mental acknowledgement of the existence of God and that
God is one.
That is the rejection of idolatry and polytheism and the idea that God is one.
So now faith therefore for James is not the same kind of thing as faith is for
Paul.
And that's why you can have Paul saying you're justified by faith and James
disagreeing with him,
but saying,
look,
even demons have faith.
They believe and they're not saved by it.
So you have to have works also,
but also works is not really the same thing for Paul.
As for James,
remember I talked about how the traditional way of understanding Paul,
this sort of Lutheran way was that when Paul is talking about salvation by works
versus salvation by faith,
what he's talking about,
and this is sort of the Protestant way of thinking,
ah,
this become more popular than modern world work stand for anything humans can
do.
So for Martin Luther works weren't just circumcision,
are keeping cash route,
are keeping the sabbath.
In other words,
works of the Jewish law.
For Martin Luther works where indulgences sold by the Roman Catholic Church
works were be even being baptized works where uh,
confessing and doing penance for Martin Luther the works he was saying,
don't save you were any activity that human beings do in order to try to earn
their own salvation.
That's not what works are for Paul.
When Paul talks about works in Romans,
he's clearly talking about works of Jewish law.
He's talking about circumcision.
Now.
I'm not saying that that means that you can't read Paul as a protestant.
If you want to read positive Protestant,
that's fine.
You can read a certain kind of idea of salvation by grace through faith,
apart from even human endeavor in Paul's letter to the Romans,
but that's not the main thing he would.
Paul was talking about,
the main thing Paul was doing was trying to get gentiles in Rome,
not to feel like they had to keep Jewish law,
but also then not to despise Jewish followers of Jesus and not to despise
Israel.
So Romans is a complicated letter,
but it wasn't as simple as you might get the idea from traditional Protestant
piety,
which is works our human activity period.
That is obviously what James takes works to be right?
Because he's not talking about works of Jewish law.
He's not talking about circumcision.
There's nowhere in the letter of James that he tells his followers,
you have to be circumcised.
There's no worry.
He says you have to keep the sabbath.
What he does say is you've got to take care of the poor.
You have to do justice.
You have to do right things.
So notice how the social situation of James Churches might tell us something
about why he comes to a belief in faith that he does and why he comes to a
belief about works that he does.
Look at James Two one through seven and remember now when I was reading about,
I mentioned Searac,
uh,
and these other wisdom literature that mentioned the poor my brothers do you
with your acts of favoritism that is favoring the rich in your church.
Really believe in our glorious Lord Jesus Christ.
If a person with gold rings and and find clothes come into your assembly,
if a poor person is in dirty clothes also comes in,
you take no notice of the one wearing the fine clothes and say,
have a seat here please.
While to the one who was poor,
you say,
stand there or sit at my feet.
Have you not made distinctions among yourselves and become judges with evil
thoughts?
Listen,
my beloved brothers has not God chosen the poor in the world to be rich in faith
and to be heirs of the kingdom that he has promised to those who love him,
but you have dishonored the poor.
Is it not the rich who oppress you?
Is it not?
They who drag you into court?
Is it not they who blasts fame?
The excellent name that is invoked over you.
James is written not to the rich.
It's written to the poor and so it's saying,
don't kowtow to the rich and your town.
Don't give them the best places in church.
Look at James Five one two six he gets really heated towards the end of the
sermon because it actually reads more like a sermon than it does a letter.
Come now you rich people.
Now he's talking to the rich,
but I think he's kind of talking to the rich with the understanding that his
real audience of the poor,
he wants them to overhear him condemned the rich,
weep and wail for the miseries that are coming on you.
Your riches have rotted.
Your clothes are moth eaten.
Your gold and silver has rested.
Their rust will be evidence against you and it will eat your flesh like fire.
You have laid up treasure for the last days.
Listen,
the wages of the laborers who mowed your fields,
which you kept back by fraud,
cry out and the cries of the harvesters have reached the ears of the Lord of
hosts.
You have lived on the earth in luxury and pleasure.
You have fattened your hearts in a day of slaughter.
You have condemned and murdered the righteous one who does not resist you.
James is written to a Christian community that's apparently either very Jewish
or he himself is writing from a very Jewish kind of point of view.
And he uses this wisdom tradition of Jewish literature that's already very well
known by the time you've got all kinds of books in this kind of wisdom
tradition.
And he uses common sayings,
but notice what kind of context he's writing.
He's writing in a context where most of the,
the members of this church are poor,
not wealthy,
and he's riding to condemn the rich for not taking that into account.
So when James says you can't have,
you can't be saved by faith apart from works.
What are the work she's talking about justice.
Yeah.
It started like that bumper sticker that says you can't have peace without
justice.
Some people running around the world saying,
Oh,
let's have pizza.
Let's have peace,
let's have peace.
Well,
it's easy to say if you're rich or you're middleclass.
But if you're poor and you're oppressed than just hotter,
hollering about peace all the time.
Doesn't sound very just does it.
Yeah.
So the bumper sticker,
if you want peace work for justice.
That's where James's,
so what works for James doesn't is not talking too much about circumcision.
The sabbath keeping kosher like it seems to Ben.
For Paul,
what he's talking about is you have to have justice.
So it's almost as if the writer of James is in a social situation where he
didn't have the luxury of teaching salvation by faith alone.
He needed to talk about what you needed to do to supplement your belief that God
exists with pursuing justice toward the poor.
That means that,
and here's the debate among scholars.
Some people have given this answer of why James and Paul don't really disagree,
because as some of you already picked up,
they're working with what seemed to be different definitions of both faith and
works,
but clearly James thinks he's disagreeing with some kind of version of
Christianity that looks an awful lot like Paul's letters.
James May think he's disagreeing with Paul even.
It's hard to say.
He doesn't ever mention by name,
but this rider may indeed think he's disagreeing with another form of
Christianity that he may view as dangerous because if it teaches you that you're
justified by faith alone,
apart from works,
then that may let a lot of rich people off the hook.
They don't have to do anything to prove their faith.
So James and Paul May indeed still being something of a disagreement,
although you can see how they wouldn't be disagreed with each of the quite
directly.
But James is operating in a system,
in a situation where it's almost as if he looks at some gospel that says,
you're not saved by works.
You're saved by faith.
And he says,
well,
that's nice and convenient for those people who don't want to work for justice.
So he writes his letter giving actually even interpreting the same verses from
genesis that Paul had used,
but using them to emphasize justice as the work that has to supplement your
faith rather than an idea that you're saved by faith alone.
So does he disagree with Paul?
Maybe yes,
maybe.
No.
Maybe it's a little bit of both.
Does he have a different view of law?
Maybe yes,
maybe.
No.
That's for you to decide and to write your paper about this week are make
scintillating comments and your discussion sections,
questions,
comments,
outbursts.
We're more than halfway through the semester.
You're not confused about anything.
Good.
I'm such a good teacher.
See you next week.